the Joe Rogan experience some people are
gonna hear what I just said about you
know medicare for all single-payer
health care and they're gonna say yeah
but how we gonna pay for it because
that's the common one that sure will
bring up now let me address that because
that's a really important question and
usually when you actually substantively
address it people go oh okay that makes
a lot more sense how are they gonna pay
so very simply put the way the system
works right now it costs more than if we
had Medicare for all why is that because
we have an unnecessary for-profit
middleman that essentially acts like a
mafia so what we're saying is I'm gonna
remove that mafia from around your neck
and you're gonna it's basically what is
that mafia you referring to that mafia
is the for-profit health insurance
company so they have to they have to
take their cut as the middleman between
you and your doctor okay if we just
remove that have the government at no
profit margin be the single insurer
that's what a single-payer means they're
the single insurer then we actually end
up saving five trillion dollars over the
course of ten years and that's not Kile
kolinsky talking that's a detailed study
from the University of Massachusetts
Amherst now talking that's a liberal
[ __ ] place so what do you do when you
have all these insurance companies like
what happens those insurance companies
well they lost all those jobs what
happens all that money the insurance
companies go away go away I mean they go
Weston says go under so you kill yet if
I if I say you're not allowed to cut
your lawn okay unless let's say the guy
wants to charge you $100 right I say no
Joe I'm I'm gonna be the one who pays
the person who cuts your lawn you have
to give me $200 okay so if somebody came
along and said no whoa whoa whoa
hey middleman guy we're gonna get rid of
you and Joe you want to cut your lawn
give that guy hundred dollars and you're
all set
wouldn't you say well that makes sense I
the middleman guy it's he can piss off
that's the way I look at it the reality
is when people argue for choice and
health insurance look at it like this
would you say hey man don't take away my
choice when it comes to picking my
firefighter people what do you mean no
the way it works is there's a fire and
you get help end of discussion
they will come you don't say well well I
want to pick my fire department well
this is the same thing with health care
the idea you're gonna be able to pick
your doctor that's perfectly fine okay
the idea of you'll have your choice
between insurance companies that's like
saying pick which much do you want the
Irish mafia ripping you off or the
Italian mafia pick ripping you off for
the Jewish mafia ripping you off go
ahead I'm giving you choice right right
in some areas the the idea of choice is
fundamentally absurd it's like saying
well let's hat let's shut off the road
system instead of being public let's
have it privately run and you could turn
make a left on that road make a left on
that road or make a right on that road
don't take away my choice of road I want
to pay for that one or that one or that
one no it's all there it's all free at
the point of service and this is the
whole idea of having a public utility
there's the whole idea of having
something that's off the table in a
civilized society right and again what
the studies show is it actually saves
money so the real question people should
be asking is how can we afford to keep
having the system that we have right now
because we pay more than the rest of the
developed world and we have thirty to
forty five thousand Americans that die
every year because they don't have
access to basic health care and we have
five hundred thousand people who go
bankrupt as a result of medical bills so
what you're saying is that they would it
would abolish insurance companies
essentially so there is one caveat to
that and that caveat is what's called
supplemental health insurance so what
that means is if there's something that
Joe Rogan likes that's a medical
procedure that isn't scientifically
proven yet but it's still something that
you like there would be private health
insurance companies that sell you
supplemental insurance which means on
top of everything that you already have
through Medicare for all so if you were
giving like stem-cell therapy or
something else temps in in an ideal
Medicare for All system and Burney
believe me has gone so far above and
beyond any criticism I mean his thing is
airtight it gives dental it gives vision
it gets everything I wouldn't be
surprised if under that Medicare for all
bill the stem cells thing is covered but
let's say something like homeopathy
which is like the wasa horseshit total
horseshit
cover that buy insurance no Medicare for
all would not cover that because it's so
speculative and it's relevant horseshit
insurance private horseshit insurance or
or or plastic surgery things of that
nature but that's an important point
because real they have private surgery
or private insurance for for plastic no
no I'm saying it would they don't
theoretically legal for it under a
medicare-for-all system because it's
supplemental how could you have
insurance for plastic surgery like you
know I decided my ears are too big so
maybe the market maybe the market
wouldn't be there but it would be
legally possible is the point so it
doesn't fully ban private insurance when
it bans what's called duplicative care
so you can't say hey I'm an insurance
company I'm gonna come in and offer you
something that's already covered in full
by the single-payer system and the
reason why that's there is we don't want
you getting ripped off by some charlatan
that's similar you say but it was it
would essentially gut the health
insurance industry it would make it so
that you no longer have health insurance
company CEO is making tens of millions
of dollars off the backs of people while
people die because they can't get health
insurance yes it would and that's a good
thing that's a positive thing it's a
good thing for us but as a sale like to
sell that well well the thing is there's
we have this issue where we have like a
status quo bias where people think like
well because it works how it works right
now therefore the idea of addressing it
and changing it seems like so
overwhelming that we just kind of
default to how we have it now
but the problem is we know as a matter
of fact that the way we do it now is the
most batshit crazy way you could
possibly do it because they research
this stuff all the time they study this
stuff all the time and every single time
they look at it the u.s. comes dead last
in the developed world when it comes to
health care so we finished there was a
recent study from the Commonwealth Fund
they found that they studied eleven
different countries the u.s. is 11th out
of 11 when it comes to health care so
every other country that does the
single-payer system which we were
talking about and there's different
versions of it there's multi-payer
there's single-payer there's private
funding of beauty there's public funding
of private insurance public funding of
public insurance but bottom line is any
other way you do it is better than the
way we do it right now hmm okay and just
to be clear because some people say well
what about Obama care what was Obamacare
Obamacare was originally a Heritage
Foundation plan which is a right-wing
think-tank so that was basically Mitt
Romney's health care bill Newt
Gingrich's health care bill and the
whole idea was that of that was we're
gonna force people to buy private
insurance right and that's not I don't
like that idea at all I dislike that
mess I've been very critical of Obama
care I think there's a good case to make
that it was a step in the right
direction because anything was better
than the system that we had at the time
but I would say that was just a little
step on the path to what we should have
which is a Medicare for All system where
health care is a right and not a
privilege we catch up to the rest of the
develop world and again we should go
above and beyond the rest of the world
because like in Canada I don't think
they have dental covered by it but
Bernie's bill does provide dental so you
know I think that this is one of those
issues where when it's fully explained
to people it's kind of a no-brainer and
you can get people to realize like no no
no the system is totally screwing you
right now and we can fix it
[Applause]